[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le général de Gaulle a expliqué aux
Français sa proposition tendante à faire
élire le Président de la République au
suffrage universel
le projet
que je vous soumets propose
que le Président de la République
votre président
soit élu dorénavant par vous-même
rien n'est plus républicains rien n'est
plus démocratique
j'ajoute que rien n'est plus français
tant cela est clair simple et droit
cette proposition est le recours au
référendum devait susciter une crise
ministérielle le message du chef de
l'État aux assemblées lui au Sénat par
monsieur Marius Moutet doyen d'âge avait
été suivi par l'élection pour la 17e
fois de Monsieur Monnerville à la
présidence de cet assemblée trois jours
avant au Congrès radical de Vichy le
président du Sénat avait pris violemment
position contre cette novation
constitutionnelle
à l'Assemblée nationale au cours d'une
séance dont le président Chaban-Delmas
fut maîtriser les mouvements de fièvre
le long de 25 interventions parmi
lesquels celle de Paul Reynaud et de Guy
Mollet monsieur Pompidou devait être
victime du vote de censure acquis par
280 voix sur 480 le gouvernement était
donc renversé
le général de Gaulle a suivi pas moins
le programme qu'il s'était fixé comme il
était prévu il alla assisté au
manoeuvres de champagne dont le double
but était de montrer au pays son armée
en cours de reconstruction en métropole
et de replacer les soldats dans la
perspective qui doit être la leur au
cours des prochaines années
dans une forte ambiance atomique comme
dit le programme les troupes des deux
camps rouge et bleu devaient mettre en
action un matériel nouveau entièrement
français et dont l'usage dans les
conditions réelles de son emploi à
passionné les observateurs
[Musique]
c'est sur un sentiment de satisfaction
que le général de Gaulle a qui revient
l'initiative de ces manœuvres a quitté
le théâtre des opérations pour regagner
Paris ou l'attendait les soucis de la
crise
[Musique]
c'est donc seulement le lendemain qu'il
reçut monsieur Pompidou venu lui
apporter la démission du gouvernement et
qu'il décidait de dissoudre l'Assemblée
en attendant les élections monsieur
Pompidou était maintenu dans ses
pouvoirs de Premier ministre
conformément à la Constitution le
général de Gaulle consultait le
président du Sénat monsieur monerville
et le président de l'Assemblée monsieur
chaban-delma il y aura donc des
élections législatives après le
référendum dont le président de la
République disait avec cette force et
cette émotion
quant à moi
chaque oui
de chacune de celle de chacun de ceux
qui me leur a donné
ne sera la preuve directe
de sa confiance et ne son encouragement
ce sont donc vos réponses
qui me diront
le 28 octobre
si je peux et si je dois
poursuivre en attache au service de la
France
vive la République vive la France
[Musique]
qu'un homme part effectuer 6 fois le
tour de la terre n'étonne plus personne
aujourd'hui Walter skyrin 9e cosmonaute
et 3e américain a tenté l'expérience n'a
donc pas fait Alté les foules comme
l'avait fait Glenn ou Carpenter dans son
étroite cabine pourtant le compte à
rebours n'en fut pas moins
impressionnant
[Musique]
avait parfaitement enlevé la capsule
Mercury et ce qui ira déjà s'entretenait
avec Slayton au contrôle de cap canavera
après avoir traversé les couches froides
de la haute atmosphère la cabine était
placée sur orbite ce qui rend
réussissait parfaitement ces six tours
de terre
le voyage de Lorette et d'assise pin-up
avait été le dernier pape à le faire en
1857 durant près de 100 ans ses
successeurs s'étaient interdit de
voyager en décidant de se rendre en
pèlerinage dans les deux cités italienne
Jean 23 a fait un geste qui peut passer
pour assez extraordinaire et qui prend
une importance toute spéciale à la
veille de l'ouverture du Concile
écumelique il devait s'en expliquer dans
la basilique de leur intensé perdre ce
pèlerinage s'ajoute à toutes les
supplications qui dans tous les temples
du monde d'Orient et d'Occident se sont
élevés vers Dieu pour un heureux
déroulement des grandes assises et
communiques en faveur de l'amour
fraternel de la paix de la grandeur de
la famille et du travail
[Musique]
le 49e Salon de l'automobile c'est
d'abord celui de la grande confrontation
européenne face au firs en anglais
italienne allemande qui ont notamment
engagé la bataille des petites voitures
pas de révolution des modèles éprouvés
améliorés chez les constructeurs
français chez Panhard la pl1763 a accru
la puissance de son moteur ses 4
vitesses sont synchronisées son capot
plongeant abrite la route secours
au-dessus du moteur la famille compte
désormais un break élégant espacieux et
version commercialisée du modèle
victorieux 24 Heures du Mans la CD
la Simca 1000 reste si l'on peut dire le
fer de lance de la firme de Poissy
grande habitabilité et dans le coffre
grand espace pour les bagages puissances
améliorer version de luxe métallisée
tels sont les caractéristiques du modèle
63 une nouveauté le coupé Simca 1000 car
sépare Bertone
[Musique]
reste fermement fidèle au rendez-vous la
404 offre désormais une version
familiale quant au moteur à injection
indirecte il équipe les deux modèles de
luxe de la firme le cabriolet et le
nouveau coupé 4004 qui attire les
regards
les améliorations sur la gamme DR4 chez
Renault une 6 cylindres 6 places la
ramblait
mais la nouveauté se trouve sous le
capot de la R8 comme sous celui de la
Dauphine la boîte de vitesse automatique
selon les nécessités de la route les
vitesses sont désormais laissées au
choix d'un cerveau électronique plus de
leviers de vitesse des touches comme sur
un poste de radio et seulement deux
pédales accélérateur et frein le
conducteur de demain sera un être comblé
Longchamp pour le Prix de l'Arc de
Triomphe c'est le métro à l'heure de la
sortie des bureaux on s'y Entertainment
pour apercevoir son favori parmi les
deux douzaines de concurrents qui
prennent le départ sur les 80000
spectateurs il y en a tout de même
quelques-uns pas beaucoup qui
aperçoivent de temps à autre le bout de
la queue d'un cheval pour notre
caméraman avec son œil à longe pas de
souci il suit la course comme dans un
fauteuil
dernière ligne droite c'est là que les
cardiaques risquent la crise on a parié
des milliards dans cette course c'est la
fortune pour ceux qui ont misé sur un
outsider s'il gagne bien entendu
jusqu'au poteau 4 chevaux donnent encore
des sueurs froides à leur supporter
c'est le plus grand des quatre chevaux
qui se dégagent à longue foulée dans les
derniers mètres c'est le numéro 14
saltico on l'attendait pas mais il a
tout de même fait des heureux ceux qui
ont parié sur lui et qui touche la
grosse côte le possesseur du billet
gagnant de la Loterie Nationale qui
empoche 200 millions et aussi sa
propriétaire madame deldeka qui gagne 84
millions et des poussières
[Musique]
c'est tambour battant que démarre les
Français maillots foncé devant les
footballeurs anglais à Sheffield vif
incisif virevoltant les Français
s'amusent de leurs adversaires qui
paraissent figés comme les tours d'un
château de sa gracieuse majesté
papa numéro 9 s'en donne à cœur joie
résultat
il semblait de voir en amener
beaucoup les autres buts on les a
attendus mais ils ne sont jamais venus
ainsi petit à petit les Anglais ont pu
refaire le terrain perdu et en deuxième
mi-temps ils ont parfois donné
l'impression qu'il jouait aussi bien que
les Français
ce n'était là qu'une impression et comme
la chance était avec eux l'arbitre leur
a fait un petit cadeau en leur donnant à
penalty une aubaine que les Anglais
n'ont pas manqué mais qu'importe ce
match nul pour les Français qui sont
désormais repartis du bon pied
[Musique]